what is the volume of this box drag on
the box to rotate it so this is pretty
neat we can actually sit and rotate this
box but we've already seen we and here
it looks like everything's being
measured in meters so we want to measure
our volume in terms of cubic meters
that's going to be our unit cube here so
when we want to think about how many of
how many cubic meters could fit in this
box we've already seen examples that you
really just have to multiply the three
different dimensions of this box so if
you wanted the number of cubic meters
that could fit in here it's going to be
six meters six meters times 8 meters
times 8 meters times 7 meters which is
going to give you something in cubic
meters so let's think about what that is
6 times 8 is 48 let me see if I can do
this in my head
48 times 7 that's 40 times 7 which is
going to be 280 plus 8 times 7 which is
56 280 plus 56 is going to be 300 and
336 336 let's check our answer let's do
one more of these so what's the volume
of this box well once again we have its
height at 6 feet now everything's being
measured in feet we have its I guess we
could call it its width being 4 feet so
we can multiply the height times the
width of 4 feet and then we can multiply
that times its depth of 2 feet so times
its depth of 2 feet so 6 times 4 is 24
times 2 is 48 feet 48 and I should say
cubic feet we're saying how many cubic
feet can fit in here when we multiply
the various dimensions measured in feet
we're essentially saying we're counting
almost how many of those cubic feet can
fit into this box